from the Philadelphia Inquirer Jeff
McLain here on the program how are you
Jeff favorite thanks for calling it we
appreciate you uh given the viewers and
and listeners of the show the straight
four one one if you will what what is
the deal with Carson Wentz as you know
it right now Jeff well he has a
fractured vertebra and that was they
found that out today they did a series
of tests CT scan on Wednesday
I don't believe revealed it but an MRI
did I did and they believe that you go
be fully recovered but he probably needs
this amount of time to get there that
being said they haven't rolled him out
yet officially for Sunday I think this
pretty much takes him out for Sunday
yeah but the rest of season is still up
in air because you can some guys can
play with that but quarterback and you
know can consider where the Eagles are
they've almost asked mathematically out
of the playoffs would suggest that maybe
they'll just set it they'll shut them
down for this so I mean they're they're
they're only half game out Jeff
obviously and you know we've seen we've
seen stranger things happen to me this
you know you could just basically run it
back if you will best you possibly can
with Nick Foles but before we get to
that I have just a few more questions
here so are we to glean from all of this
that the Eagles ran a test on Wentz just
today or yesterday with results today
that they had not yet run on him or or
did he now after the back in the Dallas
game I mean what what do we know here
well the team is not first off the team
has not officially said anything beyond
what Doug had said on Wednesday that
Carson had been experiencing back
soreness he said it wasn't related to
what happened and you know anything from
the Cowboys game now back in October he
popped up on the injury report for the
first time out of nowhere with you know
quote-unquote back injury and he was
only limited for two practices I think
was success of Thursday's in mid-october
and you know at the time the team was
saying oh this is nothing - because
about that just you know that they need
to write something on the injury report
blah blah blah but ends up being that it
was something that had been bothering
him for a while in fact he did he had
some of you know specialists flown out
from LA to help treat it now he was the
only player that got treatment from that
specialist but again it was something
that he had been dealing with and
apparently the Eagles had been testing
it but nothing popped up but they're
trying to find out is when it actually
happened but they've yet to you know
figure that out they still have to from
what I understand Carson's still going
to go seek uh you know outside medical
opinion to see you know if there's
anything more there you know what
exactly happened so this thing is not
it's a little fluid yeah I mean yeah I
know so to speak right Jeff Battaglia of
the Philadelphia Inquirer here on the
show so when you seek an outside opinion
though that that that that kind of can
be construed and I know that there is an
already talked in your area on airwaves
right now as this is breaking that there
is a level of trust potentially between
Wentz and the Eagles that has been
breached would you say that that's a
fair and accurate assessment or unfair I
would say right now it's unfair he is
not said as much okay and we are
obviously waiting for him to talk
publicly but what I will say is that the
Eagles went out this offseason and
changed their medical staff oh you know
their top two doctors were fired this is
after they want a Super Bowl mine you
talk to doctors were fired no
explanation was given and they hired a
new staff most of the guys were new guys
who also work with the Sixers the tattoo
doctors there and since then we've seen
a lot of irregularities that normal tees
when it comes to when it comes to the
medical staff when it comes to the
injuries because I've had a lot of them
certainly a lot of them were just you
know bad luck well it was thought to her
for instance they've had a number of
them some of them weird Darren Sproles
was out for 11 weeks had to
reoccurrences of a hamstring strain
Sydney Jones right now has had two
recurrences of a hamstring strain they
misdiagnosed Jie when he tore his ACL
they put him back out there with a knee
brace and then later on we found out he
tore his ACL
some of the recoveries have taken longer
than usual Chris Maragos says torn
ligaments but typically the injury takes
about a year he's still out with no
signs of him ever coming back at all
this season so there's been questions
raised and then top of that there's a
bunch of players that are not using the
doctors are going back to some of the
old doc doc going back to one of the old
doctors that they've had or no kidding
that and while that isn't only strange
because a lot of times guys do see you
know outside opinion or they do seek
outside treatment it seems like this is
happening more than ever ha Jeff McLean
of the Philadelphia Inquirer here okay
so are we going information it's sure no
no but that's that's that's why we have
you I mean you're right there on the
ground there in Philadelphia and that
might be leading to a lot of the
speculation that as you were pointed out
some of his unfair and unfounded right
now so when are we going to now have a
conversation about his I guess his
sturdiness or his or again his his
risk-taking that he constantly seems to
take hits are we gonna revisit this
conversation now do you think Jeff I
think it's fair I mean so the last four
year he's had four years he's had more
injuries there's a senior year of
college he broke his wrist that was kind
of a freak thing but still it happened
his rookie season during pre-season
first preseason game he kind of extended
to play against the Packers and got and
got hit pretty hard and broke a couple
ribs that kept him out for the rest of
preseason you did return for the for the
first game and played all 16 games at
his rookie year last year we all know he
tore the ACL in the LCL in his left knee
nearly almost exactly a year ago in Los
Angeles were there play this Sunday
missed the first two games of the season
as they recover that from that and then
had played 11 games so far this year but
is now likely to miss at least one game
this year so that's four injuries when
you're when you bring up the whole kind
of reckless thing that's something I
wrote about a number of times this
offseason because there were a plenty of
examples of him extending plays too long
to the point of just you know it wasn't
necessary for him or for him diving or
taking along defenders when really a
slide was really all that he needed to
do or run out of balance to protect
himself but honestly for the most part I
feel like he's done that this season now
that may have something to do the fact
that he's in pain he's had back issues
and what a lot of people thought off iya
keep wondering is what happened to the
Carson ones that we saw preemie injury
the one who was kind of I wouldn't say
taking on undue risk the guy that was
able to kind of escape from from you
know certain doom they had oh one he
hasn't running as much that's the guy
that people have been wondering where
he's been but in terms of the injuries
and whether he's been too reckless I
mean that's oh that's so fair you know
it's a fair question to raise whether he
is injury prone because now it's four in
four years last one for you Jeff in
terms of running it back here now here's
Nick Foles right now everyone can think
that you can bust the dog masks back out
again right everybody is overlooking
them nobody believes they have a shot
you know obviously there's no joy or
Blount walking through that door there's
a banged-up secondary but there is
darren sproles there is golden tate what
do you think is that is that the the pot
is that in the ether at all do you think
Jeff McLean well did a great job of
writing that way the underdog wave last
year he's kind of struggled with the new
message this year so maybe yeah they
pick up where they left off with Nicole
look I you know this team has many more
issues than than what than just you know
the quarterback issue even when it comes
in there in place as he did during the
during the postseason you know aside
from the injuries they just you know
offensively they just it just hasn't
been there they've only scored 20 points
in the first quarter all season which
has last in the NFL dogs play calling
has been suspect and the defense is you
know yeah the secondaries been battered
but even before they started suffering
all those injuries in the back seat in
the defensive backfield they weren't
getting the job done especially in the
fourth quarter and they blew a few games
certainly against the Panthers so this
team has that systemic issues all season
I just you know and then go and go into
LA and having the face you know Rams
team that's coming off a loss and we
know how exposed that they could be on
all offense I mean that could be
the final nail for this team any sense
of john d filippo out there making him
Hugh Jackson part two fired and then
joining a team couple sue Peterson said
no way you know he respects John but no
he's good with the guys that he has now
and and you know realistically I mean I
just didn't see him bringing in somebody
because that would undermine Mike Rowe
who replaced Frank Reich as offensive
coordinator right and press Taylor who
plays jaunty Philip Louis quarterbacks
coach and you know if they were close to
getting the playoffs maybe you pulled
josh mcdaniels you bring back a guy like
that that to help get you know over the
over that that last step there but but
considering the situation I just don't
see Doug doing that Jeff thanks for the
call appreciate it really appreciate you
getting on the phone line and giving us
the the latest
that's Jeff McLean you back there's you
bet thank you that's Jeff proclaim of
the philadelphia inquirer the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience